bonjour ont ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec à mes
côtés de quelques années bonjour katia
bonjour a tous notre invité cette
semaine et fabienne keller bonjour on
fumait pas l air du bas-rhin membre
fondatrice de agir agir ces nouveaux
nous expliquer exactement quel les deux
philosophies de ce nouveau parti
politique c'est la droite constructive
pour ceux qui seraient déjà impatient de
savoir et dans l'actualité cette semaine
la réforme des frais de mandat qui
rentre en vigueur
les députés seront bientôt remboursés
sur justificatif les sénateurs à
majorité de droite ont adopté leur
version du projet de loi de finances ils
maintiennent par exemple la taxe
d'habitation et du mouvement aussi dans
les groupes politiques à l'assemblée
comme au sénat d'ailleurs la
recomposition politique elle est loin
d'être terminée et on va commencer par
cette petite révolution en marche au
palais bourbon la fin de certains
privilèges pour les députés
jusqu'à présent les députés pouvaient
utiliser presque comme il voulait leur
indemnité de frais de mandat
désormais les nouvelles règles prévues
par la loi sur la transparence entre en
vigueur
explications de maïté frémont chaque
député disposera d'une avance sur frais
de 5300 73 euros par mois soit le même
montant que l'actuel y rfm il pourra
dépenser cette somme
seule différence hormis 150 euros par
semaine toutes les autres dépenses
devront être justifiées que ceux qui
disent que ça ne change rien regarde
comment ça se passait avant les députés
étaient simplement tenus de signer une
déclaration annuelle sur l'honneur
disant qu'ils avaient bien respecté les
règles et il n'y avait aucun contrôle
désormais entre 140 et 150 députés
seront tirés au sort chaque année ils
devront alors fournir à la déontologue
de l'assemblée tous les justificatifs de
leurs dépenses l'objectif contrôler au
moins une fois chaque député pendant la
législature
parmi les dépenses interdite
l'allocation d'un pied-à-terre en
circonscription le financement d'un
parti politique et surtout l'achat d'une
permanence parlementaire
en revanche le député pour à la louer à
condition qu'elles n'appartiennent ni
aux députés ni à un proche
il pourra également se faire rembourser
l'achat d'une voiture mais pas dans la
dernière année de son mandat
les frais de transport en
circonscription ou encore les notes de
téléphone
nous avons prévu également que dans un
an nous fassions le bilan d'une année
d'application et s'il est nécessaire
nous ajusterons les règles au vu de
l'application
ces nouvelles règles seront mises en
oeuvre au 1er janvier 2018
il ya des nouvelles règles fabienne
keller mais l'ensemble est en même temps
n'est pas aller complètement jusqu'au
voilà par exemple écarté le
remboursement total sur frais comme cela
peut exister pour les parlementaires
britanniques par exemple est ce que vous
le regrettez est-ce que ça va assez loin
pour vous est-ce que c'est assez
transparent alors d'abord c'est
l'application d'une loi sur la
transparence est une bonne loi
sa mise en oeuvre c'est vrai qu'il ya
des détails pratiques
mais les choses me semblent plutôt bien
cadré aujourd'hui alors il faut savoir
qu'au sénat on était en avance parce que
des règles sont fixées depuis plusieurs
années sur la nature des dépenses qui
sont autorisés celles qui sont
interdites par exemple l'interdiction de
d'acheter un local il existe depuis
trois ans déjà
c'est pareil pour la rémunération d'un
assistant familial savait plus dans les
allées 4 je veux dire que la sagesse du
sénat à l'initiative surtout de gérard
larcher
conscient des exigences de transparence
l'a conduit à engager une réflexion
interne au mandat précédent et la
fixation de règles qui vont être
complétés dans quelques jours par le
sénat comme l'assemblée vient de le
faire mais mais au fond qui ne sont pas
un grand changement pour nous est ce que
vous estimez que c'est suffisant pour
répondre à la question que les français
se posent aujourd'hui parce que on va
bien des hameaux qu'ils ont pour les
parlementaires pas pour les mères bien
sûr mais pour les parlementaires
présents sur la liste pour les
politiques est ce que c'est une bonne
réponse suffisamment au moins je crois
que la transparence est une exigence
elle me semble légitime elle existe dans
beaucoup de pays démocratiques
je pense aux pays nordiques mais d'ici
cet été c'était suffisant les
propositions qui sont là c'est les
français qu'ils iront en tout cas il ya
une transparence grande qui est assuré
et des règles au fond que chacun connaît
bien c'est les mêmes règles que dans un
travail dans une mission vous ne pouvez
dépenser vos frais que pour quelque
chose qui est relatif à votre activité
de parlementaires à paris n'en
circonscription est ce que votre
réaction il ya eu d'autres réactions de
parlementaire je propose les écouter été
recueillis par stéphanie des pierres
nous sommes 177 il fallait contrôler
tous les mois
les frais afférents il faudrait
embaucher des dizaines de fonctionnaires
pour simplement s'occuper de cette ce
contrôle et donc il y aura des députés
tire au sort tous les mois et qui seront
contrôlés qui permettront donc ce
sondage de vérifier ce que font nombre
des députés et chacun se sachant
potentiellement donc soumis à ce
contrôle devra se tenir à carreau il y
avait une crainte pour les
parlementaires d'être un peu fliqué
d'être obligé de se mettre totalement à
nu
je trouve que ce qui a été adopté ce
matin va à la fois dans le sens de la
transparence qui est attendu par nos
concitoyens et aussi par le respect de
l'autonomie qui est constitutionnel du
parlementaire c'est pas la révolution
c'est pas ça qui va changer les choses
ce qui aurait changé les choses c'est
qu'on coupe le lien entre la le pardon
du monde de la finance et la politique
pas seulement pour les députés parce
qu'il faut arrêter de pointer seulement
les députés comme comme bouc émissaire
et ça en réparant conduit à interdire
toute mission de conseil avec le fait
des députés ce que n'a pas voulu en
marche bon là pour le coup c'est une
petite mesurette quoi franchement lors
des contrôles aléatoires seront
effectués pour vérifier comment sont
utilisés comment est utilisé des
enveloppes certains députés seront tirés
au sort est ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment efficace de faire ça parce que
certains en doutent
je crois que une obligation de tenue de
compte tenu de justificatifs et puis des
contrôles c'est normal c'est comme tout
un chacun dans sa vie personnelle ou
professionnelle
ça me semble de bonne et une petite
enveloppe tout de même 2 600 euros
mensuels ce n'est pas rien et menues
dépenses qui échappent à ce contrôle est
ce que c'est normal ça aussi c'est une
somme qui peut sembler un considérable
aux eaux pour les français mais c'est
vrai que nous sommes souvent sollicités
dans des fêtes d'école dans des
rencontres informelles d'associations
voilà chacun peut comprendre c'est une
somme qui peut leur paraître
considérable j'avoue être c'est pas très
loin du minimum vieillesse viendra lui
même indication effectivement près de
vous deux
oui il faut savoir aussi que et c'est là
peut-être le paradoxe que chez les
personnes qui nous invite il y à une
attente aussi que nous achetions voilà
des billets de tombola tel ou tel objet
artistique réalisée et ça c'est pas tout
si vous vous justifier ça va oui mais
voilà justement parce que toujours plus
tard ça décolle vous pouvez pas perdre
et un reçu allez on va passer à un autre
sujet de ces nappes qui a examiné le
budget cette semaine
les sénateurs ont examiné le projet de
budget pour 2010 8 il a été voté en tout
cas la première partie est largement
réécrit sujet signé clément perreault le
sénat a adopté la première partie du
projet de loi de finances pour 2010
adopté le volet recettes du budget mais
modifier en profondeur sous la houlette
des sénateurs les républicains point le
plus sensible la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'était une proposition
phare du candidat macron les sénateurs
n'en veulent pas pour le moment ils
appellent à une période d'un an de
réflexion et de concertation qu'il y
avait nécessité de refonder la fiscalité
locale
ça c'est un point sur lequel on peut
s'entendre de manière assez large et en
même temps entendre ce qui se dit par
ailleurs que cette réforme est quelque
peu précipitée et c'est l'objet
précisément de l'amendement que vous
propose la commission des finances
autre mesure clé le gouvernement veut la
suppression partielle de l'impôt sur la
fortune et son remplacement par l'ifi
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière le
sénat préfère une suppression totale de
l'isf f hertault khlifi sur les sf
pourquoi je crois que c'est typiquement
à tous points de vue
au point de vue économique le mauvais à
pau 1 à pau qui a finalement un
rendement qui est assez limité du fait
qu'à des hommes de niche un rendement
quintaux un appeau qu'un taux élevé est
un impôt qui a une base étroite autres
amendements apportés par les sénateurs
un relèvement du quotient familial de
1527 à 1750 euros par demi par le refus
des baisses de compensation de l'état
aux collectivités
la suppression des surtaxes sur l'or les
yachts ou encore les voitures de sport
et un seuil unique de 3000 euros de
revenus pour les utilisateurs de plates
formes en ligne type airbnb au delà les
particuliers seront taxés comme les
professionnels
après ce volet recettes le sénat s'est
attaqué mercredi au volet dépenses
l'ensemble du budget sera voté le 12
décembre
la femme une galère quand on est agir
donc votre nouveau parti ça veut dire
constructif comment ça se concrétise sur
le vote du budget est ce que vous avez
voté le budget tel que les sénateurs de
droite sont présentés ou est-ce que vous
êtes dit bah il faut peut-être aussi que
le point des éléments que les députés la
république en marche et modem
voter alors là nous avons voté la
première partie du budget c'est-à-dire
la fiscalité et s'agissant des
collectivités locales nous sommes très
inquiets chez agir sur la politique du
gouvernement est là la sécurité la
consolidation a porté à l'action sur le
terrain donc ce que la salle ou
habitation c'est la question d'installer
habitations absolument et les grilles de
notation donc sur la date taxe
d'habitation l'idée de donner une année
de plus pour travailler sur la fiscalité
alternative annoncé désormais par le
président de la république avant au
congrès des maires me semble être une
bonne mesure moi pour ma part que
j'approuve
il faut la lire en regard de ce qui
s'est décidée au projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale où nous
avons décidé de ne pas augmenter la csg
pour les personnes retraitées
c'est à dire pour les personnes pour
lesquelles n'y avait pas la compensation
par la baisse des charges des salariés
bien sûr là sur la feuille de paye et
vous savez qu'il ya un dispositif
spécifique prévue pour les
fonctionnaires
donc c'est il faut lire les deux mesures
en cohérence l'état actuel des choses
avant de devoir voter la totalité du
budget c'est à dire à peu près dans deux
semaines au sénat vous n'allez demandé
des garanties pour l'instant pour vous
le compte n'y est pas vous attendez de
voir
oui sur la question des collectivités
donc pour les particuliers nous nous
avons proposé de ne pas appliquer la
hausse de la csg mais de maintenir la
taxe d'habitation donc ça devrait être
en gros neutre pour les pour nos
concitoyens
mais pour les collectivités locales ça
nous permet de se donner un peu de temps
et de travailler sur les dotations
parce que si le gouvernement dit les
dotations sont stables on observe qu'à
des dotations de compensation qui elles
vont baisser
donc concrètement certaines communes et
intercommunalités vont avoir moins de
recettes d'état or ce sont des acteurs
de proximité qui sont au service de nos
concitoyens
c'est la mission du sénat de les
conforter donc en tant que constructive
oui je porte la politique du
gouvernement sur le droit du travail sur
l'europe sur l'éducation mais la
vigilance est forte sur l'autonomie est
là la puissance donnée à l'action
collective
le cadre défini aujourd'hui agir c'est
quoi ces villes est la vigie de ce
gouvernement c'est en quelque sorte oui
une vigie constructif qui souhaite que
la france avance qui souhaite que la
france réussisse
par exemple sur sur le marché du travail
vous tirait la sonnette d'alarmé quand
il le faudra mais chaque fois que les
dispositions ne nous semble pas
constructif pas aller dans le bon sens
et sur les collectivités locales c'est
même aller plus loin parce qu'on a senti
au mois de juillet au moment de la
conférence territoriale qu'il n'y avait
pas suffisamment de confiance de l'état
du président de la république à l'égard
des acteurs de terrain alors fabienne
keller cette semaine à l'assemblée une
proposition de loi modem a fait l'objet
de débats passionnés c'était ce jeudi
jusque tard à l'assemblée le texte pose
le principe d'une résidence alternée en
cas de séparation des parents il divise
profondément les députés au delà des
clivages
en tout cas au sein de la majorité le
vote pourrait même avoir lieu dans
plusieurs mois qu'est ce que vous dites
sur ce type de sujet ce qu'il faut
légiférer vite ou attendre quelle est
votre position sur la société très
sensible voilà sujets de société comme
vous le dites concerne la ville
équilibre des rythmes de la vie
quotidienne familiale
ça mérite un large débat avec les
associations familiales les juges les
travailleurs sociaux de nombreux
témoignages de familles moi même j'ai
voté par exemple relèvement de la page
de la prestation d'accueil du jeune
enfant enfin de tout ce qui contribue à
un meilleur équilibre familial en
épaulant les familles pour les mamans
qui travaillent ou les parents qui
travaillent ou sont en formation c'est
des sujets qu'ils méritent qu'on prenne
le temps parce qu'autant de situation
autant de solutions qui sembleraient
s'esquisser suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que
la loi soit toujours la meilleure
manière de décider il faut aussi
s'agissant de garde d'enfant c'est le
juge qui apprécie la situation mais je
ne trouvais parlementaire forcément de
se saisir de cette question à à regarder
voilà à regarder mais en tous les cas un
débat national sur ce sujet sur au fond
l'accueil de l'enfant dans la société
dans la famille mais aussi plus large
man c'est un débat je crois qu'il va qui
va dans le bon sens parce que c'est un
proverbe africain un enfant il s'est
levé partout son village donc c'est
vraiment c'est pas une question
simplement pour la famille nucléaire va
faire c'est une question bien plus large
on poursuit avec ce mouvement dans les
groupes politiques à la fois à
l'assemblée et au sénat
certains ont rejoint la république en
marge d'autres ont créé partie agir à
droite comme à gauche au sénat comme à
l'assemblée et bien ça bouge
explication chronologique de stéphanie
des pierres ils ont fini par franchir le
rubicon dimanche gérald darmanin et
sébastien lecornu annoncent qu'ils
rejoignent la république en marche
ces deux ministres issus de la droite
tourne donc définitivement la page des
républicains pour rentrer dans la
majorité même chose pour thierry solère
le troisième homme sur la photo en
juillet le député des hauts-de-seine
avait cofondé les constructif un groupe
qui réunit la droite pro macron à
l'assemblée
le quinquennat macron il voulait dit-il
que ça marche
aujourd'hui il est complètement en
marche souhaite dans l'immédiateté
vouloir tenir compte du fait qu'il ya
des changements politiques et qu'elle
recomposition qui se perd en ce moment
je pense que cette proposition
d'ailleurs n'est pas finie et donc
gentil à la conclusion qu'il est plus
raisonnable de le faire je le fais comme
un grand garçon comme j'ai toujours pris
toutes mes décisions et ryad m'y
obligeait mais je pense que c'est plus
raisonnable
le groupe d constructif perd donc l'un
de ses co présidents mais il ne
disparaît pas et change de nom
udi agir et indépendant thierry solère a
fait un choix individuel
il est le seul du groupe à partir à la
république en marche
nous respectons ce choix ç'a eu un
certain nombre de conséquences qu'il a
assumée dont acte
derrière franck riester les députés
constructif issus des républicains lance
un nouveau parti agir dans une tribune
publiée dimanche
ils défendent une droite humaniste
sociale et pro-européenne une droite
anti vaud qui est donc au sénat comme à
l'assemblée
la recomposition politique est en cours
parmi les fondateurs d'agir il y a
plusieurs sénateurs de droite et deux
jours après la création de ce nouveau
parti
l'un juppé est même venu rencontrer
c'est constructif du palais du
luxembourg
un rendez vous officiellement prévue de
longue date alors soutien politique ou
hasard du calendrier
en tout cas l'initiative de ces
sénateurs ne déplaît pas au maire de
bordeaux toujours construire moi je ne
suis pas quelqu'un d'instructeur au
revoir une visite qui passe mal chez les
républicains
beaucoup dénoncent les positions
ambiguës fille d'alain juppé envers son
parti à gauche aussi ça tangue c'est
l'entrée au gouvernement du député
socialiste olivier du soft qui a semé la
zizanie
l'étincelle c'est le tweet de didier
guillaume le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat qui le félicite
c'est un homme de gauche moi je ne
considère pas que parce qu on entre au
gouvernement n'est plus à gauche
j'arrive le drian est un socialiste d à
gauche il a un rôle important dans le
dans le gouvernement une position qui en
énerve plus d'un an au parti socialiste
certains sénateurs parle même de
provocation de la part de didier
guillaume ce qu'il faut qu on savoir
s'ils souhaitent effectivement continuer
à présider un groupe d'opposition où ils
souhaitent faire partie de la majorité
présidentielle ou être un groupe qui
soit minoritaire mais qui soit en
soutien au gouvernement
la prochaine réunion de groupe des
sénateurs socialistes mardi s'annonce
tendu symbole une fois encore que les
répliques du séisme politique provoqué
par l'élection d' emmanuel macron sont
innombrables
alors la recomposition voulue par
emmanuel macron touche désormais les
groupes parlementaires et ce qui est
manuel et vaincrons a gagné son pari
alors l'élection d' emmanuel macron est
un fait un majeur le fait qu'il ne soit
pas le candidat d'un grand mouvement ni
à droite ni à gauche
ça a été un choc après chacun est
responsable là où il est moi je suis
membre de l'est républicain qui a été
créé il ya 15 ans j'y suis je me suis
battu pendant toutes ces années pour
qu'il y ait un bon accueil des
centristes comme moi des personnes
modéré très heureux et nous plaît nous
avons mire
voilà nous créons agir parce que enfin
moi j'ai pris la mesure bureau politique
après bureau politique de la difficulté
à s'exprimer
à travailler aussi à rezai qui cette
difficulté
je crois qu'elle trouve sa source en
fait dans l'entre-deux tours des
présidentielles
quand on n'est pas arrivé collectivement
à dire il faut voter pour emmanuel
macron il était marine le pen en face le
front national et qu'on a rédigé un
texte très compliqué bref on avait
renoncé à cette ligne rouge vis-à-vis du
front national et à partir de là on n'a
pas su parler de cette incroyable
défaite à il ya un an exactement
on devait gagner la présidentielle la
seule question c'est est qui serait
notre champion c'est un trio aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est la droite laurent
wauquiez qui ne vous satisfait pas tel
que aujourd'hui elle se dessine moi je
dénonce
je n'annonce pas je sais c'est très
simple vous partez autre que vous fonder
un nouveau parti c'est parce que vous ne
vous reconnaissez plus dans une certaine
droite les républicains là celle de la
ligne non convoqué c'est tout à fait
cela je constate qu'il y a un
déplacement vers des idées très
conservatrice vers des thèses très
excluante je ne trouve pas de discours
européen et je ne trouve pas beaucoup de
capacité à construire à avancer à
s'ouvrir et j'ai beaucoup de mal à faire
comme un certain nombre de républicains
c'est à dire à attaquer des mesures qui
étaient dans notre propre projet donc
nous avons créé agir pour être dans une
dynamique positive pour travailler pour
être d'accord réagir mais ils
comprennent pas très bien à quoi ça va
servir à écouter le sénateur pierre
chareau vous répondra juste ans on peut
pas à la fois être agir c'étaient les
reproches du gouvernement et l air c'est
à dire dans l'opposition vous demandez
leur exclusion non je demande
l'interdiction de la double appartenance
sa part excuses ans et on est plus
sévère si on va chez agir c'est très
compliqué un rôle constructif
parce qu'il ya trois syllabes que vous
avez vu les mots goji pays ça dans cette
affaire il faut le constater et un jury
était aussi celle président de l'apli
pour parler de l'europe donc abandonné
faut clarifier les situations au moment
où on s'apprête à vivre un nouveau
président une roue une nouvelle
présidente à la tête valère
on peut pas être à moitié enceinte et on
peut pas être ce qu'on a dit chez moi
dans le loir-et-cher un beau week moitié
book moitié bic
voilà votre écoute et je laisse ces
paroles à monsieur charon c'est lui qui
les prononcent il ya eu beaucoup de noms
d'oiseaux
chez les républicains c'est pas avec ça
qu'on avance et qu'on propose un projet
pour la france
vous pouvez plus travailler ensemble les
deux gauches irréconciliables vous avez
de droite irréconciliables moi je dans
la vie politique on progresserait
beaucoup à respecter les hommes et les
femmes et à ne pas se qualifier de noms
d'oiseaux celle et constructif nous
souhaitons proposer à tous ceux qui
veulent justement construire un projet
construire une ligne mais aussi soutenir
la france qui avance
c'est à dire les vahinés cela riffier
notamment alain juppé et ce qui est
assez claire la gp quand il fait un pas
vers emmanuel macron un autre pas vers
vous alain juppé il a des convictions il
a des convictions qui sont fortes
il ya une dizaine de jours au corps tous
ceux qui ont l'ont porté pendant la
campagne des primaires étaient réunis au
sénat autour de lui il a réaffirmé ses
convictions européennes sa volonté
d'accompagner les réformes portées par
edouard philippe sur le droit du travail
est sûre l'ambiance est assez clair
c'est clair parce que c'est sur le fond
on soutient ce que nous avons nous même
portée quand on voit la politique de
l'éducation conduite par jean michel
blanquer
c'est tout à fait ce qu'alain juppé lui
même avait écrit dans son ouvrage les
chemins de l'école claude malhuret le
président du groupe des indépendants au
sénat et membre fondateur d'agir a lui
choisi clairement puisqu'il a annoncé
qu'il quittait les républicains est ce
que vous pourriez en faire de même su
écouter aujourd'hui je suis membre de
l'est républicain et j'ai choisi d'être
fondatrice avec les dix neuf collègues
de d'agir
nous verrons pour la suite ya pas de
double appartenance possible sur un
possible départ dlr oui puis sur une
poursuite de la discussion jeu j'ai
porté l'ump avec beaucoup d'autres un
parti ouvert fédérateur acceptant
différentes sensibilités
c'est d'ailleurs la démarche aussi du
groupe au sénat où l'on sait que les
groupes ne sont pas forcément à
l'identique des partis politiques aux au
sénat c'est une démarche plus
intéressante de vouloir fédérer
différentes sensibilités
j'ai du mal à y renoncer si d'autres y
renonce bon c'est leur choix
alors fabienne keller on va rester sur
la politique avec d'autres questions de
la semaine des questions européennes
pour vous alors on parlait de laurent
wauquiez et bien laurent wauquiez
considère qu'un axe central
alain juppé emmanuel macron pour les
européennes est une profonde erreur et
vous vous pensez quoi
alors moi je pense que on n'a pas pris
la mesure de l'enjeu 2019
on risque d'avoir un parlement européen
eurosceptiques dans tous les pays
d'europe
le populisme monte en puissance donc le
sujet c'est de porter une vision
l'europe n'est pas parfaite mais elle
apporte des leviers par exemple sur les
sujets de migration qui préoccupe
beaucoup nos concitoyens nous sommes
organisés à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen c'est un outil puissant qui
méritent d'être complétées pas besoin de
traiter on peut travailler sur base
intergouvernementale dès lors qu'il ya
une volonté il ya d'ailleurs eu de très
grands progrès au cours des derniers
mois à l'égard de conair entre les pros
macro et écoutez c'est beaucoup trop
devenu de descendre c'est trop tôt pour
le dire ça c'est de la stratégie parlons
du fond a quand même quelque chose qui
se dessine c'est des choses qui font en
parlons du fond et des projets ce qui se
dessine clairement c'est qu'il y en a
qui trouvent que des défauts à l'europe
c'est monsieur mélenchon c'est monsieur
le pen et c'est laurent wauquiez dans
son ouvrage il ya il ya deux ans où il
voulait en fait il est très
eurosceptique à nant dans ses écrits
même s'il a donné un correctif il a fait
du et en même temps d'ailleurs laurent
wauquiez dans sa naissance article dans
le figaro
mais il est assez eurosceptique il ne
l'a pas toujours été
dans son passé alors que celle et
constructif nous sommes la falaise elle
a même été secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes qu'est-ce qui peut
tenir ce genre de discours aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu contradictoire abba
j'observe que dans ses meetings pour les
prix
une stratégie l'aisne c'est haro sur
l'europe sa mauvaise gestion des
frontières extérieures
par exemple et de la croissance et des
perspectives européennes
peut-être une question aussi sur un
rapport qui a agité cette semaine c'est
le vote sur le glyphosate
vous avez vu qu'il ya une tension entre
les pressions de l'allemagne et de la
france en une minute est ce que vous
nous dire si le couple franco allemand
peut exploser sur cette question alors
en allemagne comme en france il y à des
tensions entre ceux qui ont plutôt
proche des agriculteurs et ceux qui sont
plutôt proche des écolos lors du lobby
agricole qui a gagné je voudrais
féliciter nicolas hulot pour sa ténacité
je pense que c'est une une bonne
direction d'avoir donné une échéance
parce qu'il faut avoir conscience que la
décision européenne ne donne pas
d'échéance autorise pour 5 ans mais on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe au bout de
cinq ans donc avoir marqué une volonté
d'accélérer la recherche et la
révolution en iran la même position sur
cette question centrale
je pense que sur ce sujet beaucoup plus
large des pesticides
il va falloir travailler comme pour la
coop et le réchauffement climatique sur
l'agression de consensus scientifique on
peut pas douter de la science en
permanence en constructif c'est un peu
ce que vous venez ça fait merci beaucoup
et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine